hey how's it going my name is Fanta you
skate oh my god you're so scared there's
no way you can possibly be scared I'm
less clicking on my videos too scary but
this game however is scary so we're
gonna keep playing it and we're gonna
start off by making a painting boom
alright that's how it's done
that's alright what is it look like a oh
god oh that's creepy as [ __ ] man
they either they changed it in an update
or it's different every time you click
it because I had to replay because my
save wasn't saved it's like you have one
job save what is this ah nice glad we
did that
alright let's keep going out there's
going to be jump scares it'll be ok
we're together
look at this wall painting that's
definitely a purple cat giant cat great
proportions there with the trees and
this is people and that's just Smurfs
having gangbang you're you're welcome
for me to let you interpret ate any kids
art at any moment I goddamn it why did I
brick wall the door ah all right let's
try but what whoa whoa calm down doors
we are friends remember no not you
alright well are we friends alright what
don't [ __ ] with my brained game yeah no
no Shh
Shh everyone chill I'm just gonna go
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him [ __ ] sir Sam Oh God
we're back in the call away I don't like
the hallway okay okay oh god oh god oh
god
gotta get that boom boom boom oh god
please no please no okay oh no god damn
my nipples are so hard I'm not even
joking I didn't know that was a thing
it's kind of nice marzia must you touch
mine
oh my load what happened in here I don't
like it
I don't like this I don't like when
they'd redecorate
marzia what did you do to this room -
what is this wait who's crying stop
crying stop crying it's gonna be okay
hey girl hey hey funny helmet Ellie oh
[ __ ] no no no no no no no no no no no I
am NOT going there mm-hmm no what oh god
no hi pretty lady
I don't I can't deal okay maybe a little
bit no no kiss god damn this game is
creepy man odds do that was I in a
steaming sacrificial again you can't
summon ducks
you just can't so I'll try another
[ __ ] are we okay yeah we okay I'll
look it's big smurf gangbang and stuff
it's quiet now Shh stupid night what is
this door why is it like don't like it
don't like it one bit
hello hey nice hat bro hey was knocking
oh god you worried it's a creepy
[ __ ] that hat though bro
like seriously where did you get it
goodwill really
is that even a hat I think it's like a
instrument maybe oh oh look at me like
that
it's just REI so just like your house is
focused on my work that's all
hey bro what ever had floats your boat
am i right ladies yes yes that was a
good one
what where am I I am going out of here
that monster in the game is so [ __ ]
creepy
ha ha [ __ ] you god damn it is success
everywhere isn't it oh shut up don't
even care
god damn it stop redecorating my yet
told you many
so I'm getting sick of that [ __ ] like
either we make out or we don't stop
[ __ ] [ __ ] teasing me cock-teasing I
don't think that's a cat damn it what to
say again god damn it I told you you
can't summon ducks what's wrong with you
everyone knows this it's in the Bible
God
oh all right this way this looks nice
assess yes up nope oh why was that what
was that I don't even care I don't even
care
I'm gonna go Emily I'm go ahead I'm
going everyone
bye-bye now that I've ever better better
better better bat bat bat bat bat books
I don't care I'm not scared anymore
look at me I'm not scared yeah this is
my not scared face what is this
books cool going in here I swear to God
I was here a second ago
but I'm not trying to percent sure of
the position now all right well all
right I'm just just keep what Oh Shh
ah baby apples my favorite apples god
damn it where did it go
Oh daddy oh thank you stop chasing me
with apples [ __ ] goddamn it ah there we
go alright we're fine
this is um too much makeup lady who is
upset over her carrots those are carrots
I know a good care all right well I'm
gonna go this way I think I'm not sure
but I have a good feeling about not that
direction this is a purple lady that
wants to hold hands that's okay
April wants to hold her god damnit all
these locked doors is this a book what
are you doing up there calm down now the
[ __ ] is a stupid paintings now at what
all right remind me to paint the ceiling
this is weird
I said woman with her melon or bowling
ball is a bowling ball yeah ah oh I seen
this room I had to replay the game in
the in the first area there there's the
baby room and I missed it in the first
time I what does it spell
are they spelling something this is
creepy I hate kids they're [ __ ]
terrifying so want to punch them in the
face it's not ethical to punch babies
though so don't tell anyone it just
looks so weird I can't it's not my fault
they look weird
alright collected something I don't know
how I don't know why I collect [ __ ]
everybody [ __ ] time oh there we go oh
I love these oh look it's the baby
apples am i riding this thing I think I
am oh I used to have one of those toys I
love those broken alright one song at a
time guys one oh mine didn't do that
though my Island I didn't have that
gravity-defying version one okay that's
creepy
can I get off this right now
oh okay Timmy we talked about doing that
all right I read Ira
okay
a candle I love candles don't like
candles
never mind hate them
oh great great great great do you don't
want to go there
hi huh I was surprising the painless
all right yes but as this was a special
brush my horsehair brush but different
at that point I hesitated will this
really work
since my pubic hair bucket I was already
halfway through and besides it's not
like I can just put it all back and
forget the whole thing that was a lot of
creepiness and a lot of oh oh [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] may have a fine very
nice good painting good painting like
this airheads
nice and cozy isn't it oh [ __ ] me that's
so disturbing Oh God
all right you bros ready to put another
piece to the puzzle you tell me Bruce
you tell me Ben what do we got what are
we [ __ ] gone oh she's so pretty
so pretty okay that was another one
let's go out and catch them all am i
right ladies sorry I'm so sorry I don't
I don't know what's wrong with me then
what do we got in here chicory
dah no no no no ducks and the car the
clock struck one okay ran down hickory
dickory dock
you sound so mean I don't like him what
about your breasts ever going back no
there's definitely weird stuff going on
here oh god oh god man it's so dark I
can't [ __ ] see and it scares the [ __ ]
out of me that rhymed alright alright
oh no no no no high fives he's jealous
of high fives brush let's sneak one oh
he's doing this I thought oh oh you
sneaky son of a Snooper what is this son
hi
wow there's
[ __ ] eyes everywhere [ __ ]
[ __ ] you Oh God
make it stop
attempting to practice jumping jumping
jumping and we need to pull something I
don't appoint boom boom boom boom boom
boom
yeah yeah that's pretty sick beatbox
right shop
stay open this is crap alright
canvas crawlers ah my favorite my
favorite mmm I wonder what the story is
in it ah I I'm like I wonder what the
story is gonna be game throws books to
me thanks thanks game I appreciate it
uh it unlocked oh god it's my sexy main
[ __ ] her name was Alice she had the
teeth of a walrus but goddamn she had a
smile of an angel
ah sketch oh they're dancing for me why
not
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] from this game tank I
got your shell pal the racks I love rats
check it out ah give me the [ __ ] out of
there oh [ __ ] me everywhere I go there's
neither tech like my toes don't know
don't summon me you can't summon me god
damn I got summon again ah
it's embarrassing it's not good for my
you to breath oh I'm sweating like a
[ __ ] gorilla on some [ __ ] tit milk
that's a thing go delay hi check your
Tammy but don't go in that beer what
so some what's in there I can't hear
just chill Joe it you can't tell me what
to do the guy can fit that's right ain't
no chain high enough the [ __ ] are you
doing Oh
stop doing that I don't like it okay so
here we are and I'm gonna pull this rope
what's that you're good you like it yeah
I like when I pull the rope
juergen I can't hear over your screaming
do you like it or do you not like it
yeah Jim you're gonna do stupid
screaming here again last time yes or no
more or not yeah he's dead
god damn uragan typically oh it's open
now thanks Garrigan yeah [ __ ] I'll ever
this is nice this makes me feel good I
feel great I love games like this this
game is so [ __ ] scary though I'm
sweating balls this is like my days
exercise I don't need it I need an
exercise I've sweated enough oh [ __ ]
we're gonna use the elevator aren't me
my golly is [ __ ] elevator now to make
sure I close it all the way and then
this way no this way
yes here we go up up up up to the top
spin around
Hey a man can like High School Musical
without having any kind of mental
problems
alright my mom told me that at least is
it malfunctioning again come on oh oh oh
oh I don't think this is good donut I
think it oh god oh god oh god oh god
it's up there oh this is really scary
oh oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me of course
I'm so sorry
oh god damn it I got summoned by the
demons again so you can technically die
in this game but you just gets resubmit
as a duck then it actually explains a
lot of things for example how there's
like no other ducks in this game because
there can only be one what do you want
shut up I'm tired of this [ __ ]
quiet quiet place Oh what's down there
hello Goten tag my name is Tobuscus no
way that's I keep mixing is that oh it's
definitely coming from here oh hello
that Freddie later that [ __ ] just
happened
what a [ __ ] just trying to beg gave her
a compliment
Jesus Christ what can we go out no all
right well I'm just gonna keep pressing
doors we did it yay gotta say the
visuals in this game is just so [ __ ]
good
that makes oh I got a phone call from
mr. baby beard ha ha ha ha isn't he's my
where's it coming from
what
what's going on oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's
coming from the wall iPhone I was
supposed to dial something in the phone
it must be a document somewhere don't
worry bro I know you're like how God not
a puzzle I don't know how to solve it
I'm an expert that is my entire
collection please ignore that one that
is my pet
mr. Bob this is my unpaid bills don't
judge I bet you have them too this is my
pen fiction arts and crafts works this
is my smoking the club with Oprah and
Snoop Dogg collection and I take back
everything I said about pop Oh mister
baby live mr. baby beard thank you
three is it is that a three mr. baby
beard look at his face that's a face of
a bun of a baby that seems some [ __ ]
three six three Thank You mr. baby beer
come on Let me kiss we always do this
baby beard three six three I got it I'll
take that well at least you got to see
my a my drawer collection I don't have
to do that tag all right we got it three
six I hope I didn't get this wrong oh
did we do it another phone it's [ __ ]
phone reception
it's coming from where she's coming from
bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
bad
stop I can't wear it better that I've
ever what does that mean mr. baby beard
help me I pray every night to you mr.
baby bed maybe we need to go out
no strange body strange uh-oh oh okay
that's unexpected what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna go guys no I can't go what the
[ __ ]
all right baby beard I'm getting sick of
this baby beard of course there's a door
that of course of course how could I not
expect that [ __ ] what it ends there
all right well fair enough